We are now learning
the identity of the American
killed by Russian artillery
in the battle
for back
to US
Army Special Forces
veteran Nicholas maMer.
Retired Army staff sergeant
seen here with Idaho
Senator James Risch
serve
more than 20 years
in uniform before retiring in 2018.
They arrived in Ukraine
in the spring of last year.
His uncle says that he'd gone there
as a quote humanitarian
trying to do good for this world.
In a video posted to Telegram
he had evolved en masse to regroup,
appeared to
show what he claimed were US
identification documents
he claimed
the American was shooting back
when he was killed in battle mode.
CNN's Clare
Sebastian is following developments.
She joins us here in London
with the latest.
Clare,
does it have any impact
when Nationals of NATO's countries
who go to Ukraine to fight
voluntarily are killed in the conflict?
You know,
I think it was interesting
that we learned
about this through that video
from Prigozhin right.
Because this comes
and obviously
his family have not responded
to requests for comment.
But his uncle did tell
the Idaho Statesman
that that was his body
that Prigozhin shows.
In this video,
we're not showing it for obvious reasons.
But he know this comes after reports
that Prigozhin
has been having trouble in Baku
and Ukraine has been making slow
an incremental advances.
His Ukrainian commander last week
accused his forces of running away.
Faced with those advances, so his ability
to go
and sort of put on this show of viewing
the body of an American killed that
allows him to
project strength to project
authority and superiority in a conflict
which we know
as you saw from that video
and by the way,
we don't know
if that video came
from the Russian or Ukrainian side
is still very intense,
very chaotic street by street battles.
I think it's striking to learn
how this American citizen died.
According to a friend of his
who also runs a nonprofit
in Ukraine,
he was in a building
that was hit
by a barrage of Russian artillery
and the buildings started to collapse.
And he this friends,
is that a lot of the Ukrainian soldiers
and foreigners
fighting there managed to escape.
But, of course,
he didn't, as it turned out.
So I think you really get a sense
of the type of battle
we're seeing, street
by street, buildings collapsing.
That's why
you see the level
of destruction in backward.
And despite
the sort of incremental progress
we're seeing from Ukraine,
it continues to be very intense
and very difficult.
Clare Sebastian, thank you
A top Ukrainian defense official claims
their forces have liberated
about 20 square
kilometers of suburbs around back
from Russian fighters.
CNN has not verified that,
but observers
think that Ukraine's gains in the region
have been more modest.
CNN's Nic Robertson spoke
with several Ukrainian soldiers
who have fought in
the bitterly contested city
war.
All I
on back looks destroyed.
Streets to Ukrainian soldiers bolster
flagging spirits with dark humor.
Oh, that boom, boom, boom.
Is that on us?
One says, oh, no.
The other jokes, we are enchanted.
They're not for us.
Russia's push for the remaining Ukrainian
controlled high rises around them
has not relented.
Despite recent successes
taking ground
north and south of the meat grinder town
in a field hospital, nearby,
troops can cast
by heavy Russian
shelling inside back mud.
How was the fighting back
compared to person in other places?
But with so much callsign wait,
a 47 year
old former warehouse
manager tells us back
it is his hardest battle yet
It's hell, he says.
How is the morale at the frontline?
He pauses, sighs and whispers.
Jiro, it's hard
Tanks, too, are getting chewed up
in the back foot meat grinder.
This Soviet era T-72 blasted by shelling.
They're repairs made in hedgerows
because workshops are getting targeted
to show the shrapnel holes don't matter.
This tank commander tells us
what's important is the engine
and the reactive armor
locations of repair.
Hideaways
like this one
are a closely guarded secret.
Once the counteroffensive begins,
they will be even more vital
to keep the military
and its machines moving strong.
In a combat bunker buried outside back.
But troops have no idea when or where
the big offensive will come.
The monitoring the battlefield from here,
we can't show you the screens
that they're looking down from drones
as soon as a Russian soldier
puts his head up and moves.
You see the morale here high
because they've recently made gains
across fields surrounding the town.
Early success
in the coming
counter-offensive will be critical
to lessons of back mud.
Momentum and motivation is all.
Nic Robertson, CNN, eastern Ukraine.